jean michel cousteau
bonsoir bonsoir bon séverine ferrer
nicolas rey laurent baffie jean michel
cousteau qui est donc le fils aîné du
commandant cousteau
voilà alors séverine pendant l'émission
c'est a du mal à suivre
si tout va bien tu es comme ça et si ça
va mal tu fais comme ça voilà ce qui
s'était passé tout comme ça et si l'on
se fait tout comme ça il a l'habitude si
tu manques des rediffs est comme ça
alors jean michel proust vous publier
mon père le commandant à l'archipel avec
cette extraordinaire photo de couverture
au moment où à l'âge de 7 ans votre père
comme vous dites vous jette à la baille
et c'est vrai que c'est une photo que
j'adore parce qu il ya dans le regard
quelque chose d'à la fois confiant et
anxieux c'est magnifique s'est souvenu
souviens très bien de toutes ces années
avec mon frère qui était plus jeune qui
lui avait été fait repoussée par dessus
bord il avait 4 ans et demi et puis on
nous emmener pendant les week-ends
pendant les vacances sont allés se
baigner nager plonger alors que nos
petits camarades d'école où il allait à
la montagne et du ski
on pensait que c'était tout à fait
normal donc si vous voulez j'ai eu le
privilège d'être un des premiers grâce à
me mettre à l'eau alors ensuite pendant
40 ans effectivement vous avez sillonné
les mers à bord de la calypso pour
réaliser votre rêve
construire des maisons sous la mer vous
donnez architectes vous n'avez jamais
fait des maisons sous la mer n'ont
jamais non j'attends toujours mon
premier client
lepage à breslau et puis vous avez
réalisé produit de nombreux films
évidemment consacré à l'océanographie à
l'environnement alors votre livre
commence par l'enterrement du commandant
cousteau a beaucoup de livres qui
commence pour des enterrements
le livre de nicole calfan enterrement
autres films aussi à 9 à 10 mhz
enterrement la comtesse aux pieds nus
oui effectivement enterrement réapprend
raconte la vie voilà
et là c'est le début d'une fin voilà
c'est un bon truc c'est le 30 juin 1997
notre dame de paris
des funeral quasi nationale en présence
du président la république pour le
fameux commandant cousteau l'homme au
bonnet rouge
et là on voit la veuve du commandant
francine avec ses deux enfants francine
qui la deuxième épouse donc du
commandant cousteau
vous citez jamais son prénom dans le
livre pourquoi parce que je pense que
c'est un personnage qui n'appartient pas
vraiment à l' aventure cousteau ah
d'accord
donc c'est pour ça vous ne citez pas son
prénom tout laventure cousteau s'est
arrêté en fait si vous voulez le jour où
ma mère est morte mère je dédie ce
bouquin à ma mère ce qui veut dire que
sans ma mère le commandant cousteau
n'ont jamais été ça l'a été
et le jour de sa mort prématurée mon
père s'est liquéfiée littéralement et à
ce moment là vous repensé au deuxième
mariage du commandant quand il a épousé
7,7 francine et en fait il n'avait pas
le droit de se marier deux fois l'église
parce que ça c'est parfaitement interdit
alors voulu poser la question est en
fait il vous répond que grâce au
révérend père carré il a obtenu le droit
de se marier deux fois et vous découvrez
que quand on est académicien finalement
ça aide
moi j'ai trouvé ça choquant
ça le regarde s il était en paix avec
lui-même ceci étant personnellement je
trouve ça très choquant mais c'est assez
dur quand vous le décrivez à genoux la
langue pendante pour recevoir l'hostie
c'est assez violent ces violences ce
sens que si vous voulez j'étais
absolument choquée de voir mon père qui
ne pratiquaient pas d'un seul coup se
liquéfier littéralement parquet pour que
beaucoup sont maintenant ça fait deux
fois que woods il s'est liquéfié s'est
quand même bien alors son premier
mariage le commandant cousteau c'est
avec votre votre mère donc on a beaucoup
dit que c'était un beau mariage qui à
l'époque était quand même une façon de
dire que c'est un mariage d'argent non
non ce n'est pas un mariage d'argent
c'était un mariage d'amour qui en
l'occurrence a permis à ma mère qui
rêvait d'être dans la marine
quant à l'époque les femmes n'avaient
pas le droit d'être dans la marine et de
ce fait elle a fait ce qui avait de
mieux à faire c'était d'en épouser un
amara ont tiré qu'à lui ça lui a permis
de pénétrer dans le milieu des affaires
comme un salut a permis sur des dents ça
lui a permis d'ouvrir des portes
ouais alors quand votre belle mère
francine cousteau était sur ce plateau
on lui a parlé évidemment des
accusations d'antisémitisme dont votre
père a été victime
et cette fameuse lettre de 1941 le
commandant cousteau vient d'arriver à
marseille
il a une famille une femme des enfants
ils n'arrivent pas à se loger est il
écrit une lettre en disant il n'y aura
d'appartements convenable que quand on
aura affiché à la porte tous les
ignobles loutres qui nous encombre alors
moi j'ai découvert ça comme vous il ya
deux ans ou trois ans j'avais jamais
entendu mon père avoir des commentaires
de ce genre là hein je trouve ça
extrêmement regrettable bien sûr c'est
une lettre privée qui était destiné aux
commandants tayeb qui a
qui a qui a été trouvée distribués mais
il faut se mettre dans le contexte de
l'époque nous étions quatre dans une
chambre à massat et au sixième étage et
on pouvait pas avoir de logement alors
que les réfugiés qui venaient d'un peu
partout eux on leur donnait des
appartements de plusieurs pièces quand
il ya eu un sou les a ras-le-bol il ya
eu un geste malheureux de sa part est
regrettable est que je condamne voilà
alors après le passage de votre belle
mère dans cette émission on a reçu un
mail le fils d'un ancien collaborateur
de votre père qui l'accusé d'avoir
déposé à son nom cette idée de détendeur
qui a fait sa fortune bien entendu qu'il
avait piqué un certain emile gagnant
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que ce
détendeur c'est quelque chose d'énorme
c'était la fin du dew du gros scaphandre
donc c'était une avancée extraordinaire
le le beau père de mon père qui était un
officier de marine qui travaillait pour
l'air liquide après sa retraite avait
mis en contact mon père avec un
ingénieur de l'air liquide
ouais et c'est emile gagnant pour
améliorer un système qui existait déjà
qui avait été inventé par le commandant
le prieur et avant le commandant prieur
qui avait été inventé par les vous
cayrol denayrouze à espalion dans
l'aveyron a donné ce détendeur votre
père il l'a piqué willard boyle a pas
piquer du tout il a ils ont adapté tous
les deux
si vous regardez le brevet ça s'appelle
cousteau gagne en pro b cousteau gagnant
donc lhi décembre les autres et à
lannion à gagnant car votre père l'idée
a été partagé entre les deux vous pouvez
parler à la fille de monsieur gagnant
qui toujours vie à une femme
extraordinaire d'ailleurs avec qui j'ai
plongé a pas très longtemps et il n'y a
jamais eu d'amertume à ce niveau là en
tous les cas pour pouvoir faire les
essais de son détendeur votre père donc
le commandant cousteau a fait appel à
son frère qui à l'époque était quand
même un personnage haut placé de la
france collaborationniste c'est pierre
antoine cousteau rédacteur en chef de je
suis partout journaleux fasciste et
d'ailleurs pierre antoine a été condamné
à mort à la libération il a été gracié
donc n'était pas antisémite mais enfin
c'est quand même servi de son frère qui
était un ponte de la collaboration pour
faire avancer son idée de détendeur je
ne sais pas exactement comment ça s'est
passé j'étais beaucoup trop jeune
là encore et je n'étais même pas à paris
j'étais à megève donc jeu
je ne suis pas un témoin direct et je
n'en connais pas vous allez leur
perplexité perplexe parce que je vais
parce que c'est la vérité parce que
votre père quand il eu besoin de faire
ces essais dans la marne il a il a
demandé d'autres villes a demandé à son
frère ce que tu es logique vous ne lirez
d'une certaine façon
enfin sauf que cela n'avait absolument
rien à voir avec la position que pouvait
avoir son frère qui était mon oncle que
je n'ai pratiquement pas connu parce que
soit elle était en prison soit il était
malade il est mort du cancer très jeune
après avoir été libéré et si vous avez
besoin d'un renseignement vous avez
besoin d'une permission vous allez voir
les gens qui peuvent vous la donner ça
absolument rien à voir avec la position
politique ou antisémite éventuelle de
son frère un bateau à éventuel à la
force contre des répondants mais quand
on dirige je suis partout pendant la
guerre de 40 c'est pas éventuel
l'antisémitisme non mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que je peux pas vous répondre
là dessus parce que je ne sais pas ce
qui s'est vraiment passé
autre reproche couramment adressé à
couche tôt et que vous abordez dans le
livre c'est le fait d'avoir maltraité
des animaux et des le monde du silence
on parle de quelques cachalot sacrifié
en fait pour une reconstitution il ya eu
il ya deux choses à dire il ya eu un
accident un accident où effectivement la
calypso est passé sur un bébé cachalot
hélas aussi sonné ce qui a été
absolument dramatique et il ya eu des
reconstitutions qui ont eu lieu plus
tard avec d'autres animaux n'oubliez pas
que nous étions des pionniers on faisait
les erreurs que font tous les pionniers
qu'on peut nous reprocher aujourd'hui
mais ça nous a appris ce qu'il ne faut
pas faire oui et bien aussi les lions de
mer la pépite au et cristobal lapébie
temps et cristobal pareil et ils sont
morts qua non bassignana qui a été
empoisonné par l'unc et crapauds buffle
c'est cristobal oui foisonner et l'autre
qui a été mis sur une île et les
relâcher au pérou alors qu'il vient de
madagascar mais tout ça c'est de
l'histoire ancienne si vous voulez et
edu
cheminement et j'espère qu'on va aller
on va aller là le président mans c'est
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pendant ces
cinquante ans ouais si on quand même pas
oublier que le commandant cousteau et
son équipe ont fait connaître la mer à
la terre entière et que peut-être après
l'abbé pierre et le général de gaulle
c'est le personnage le plus connu sur
les prés le personnage français le plus
connu sur la planète donc il ya une
raison une raison quand même dans le
positif
tu sais tout ça toi non mais sinon trois
séverine tu aime tout ce qui est
langoustines crevettes pour tasser
bigorneaux oui les bulots les met près
puisque même si excellent tu es déjà
dans un âge aiderait géant vous ce que
vous voulez pas de physique on a dit oui
alors les linguistes les processions des
langoustes et la procession de
langoustes comme les crevettes et commué
requins ce sont les éboueurs de la mer
lorsque vous vous régaler avec des
crabes des animaux qui sont des pro
hamas les morts les blessés et mal
formés qui sait les crabes les araignées
sont les langues où sera aussi aller
omar aussi oui et les huîtres alors
parlons pas des huit avants et filtre
tout alfie faute ou grâce à nos
intérieurs et du manger tout en prusse
commandant j'ai l'impression vous
enlevez loin le coeur le foie à la une
huître ou danger tout beau votre père
était pas tendre avec les animaux on
vient de le voir mais pas non plus avec
les gens ils étaient très durs neufs
c'est dur parce qu'il était très
déterminé il savait où il voulait aller
et
dans la mesure du possible rien ne
l'arrêté ouais c'était aussi bien avec
sa famille qu avec des gens qui
l'entourent avec vous il a été terrible
avait ouvert un truc qui s'appelait le
cousteau fidji island resort est un qui
s'appelle maintenant de jean michel
cousteau est un complexe touristique
dans le pacifique sud est et ils vous
avez un procès sans même vous appeler il
m'a intenter un procès m'a pas fait un
procès à intenter un procès qui a été
arrêté et j'ai mis mon nom mon prénom
devant mon nom
toute ma vie moi j'avais fait du
cousteau et puis d'un seul coup dont
j'ai eu l'honneur de mettre nos prénoms
devant oeuvre ceci étant vous savez
malheureusement à l'époque où ça ça
s'est passé alors que mon père m'avait
dit tu sais les avocats il faut jamais
se mettre de l'impact parce que c'est
eux qui gagnent et les autres perdent
toujours
asseyons-nous autour d'une table avec
une bonne bouteille de pinard et on
règle tous nos problèmes
1 et bien malheureusement il ya eu des
gens au milieu qui ont été référées à
une époque oui où il commençait à
vieillir et ça s'est mal passé c'est
devenu très public mais je peux vous
dire que il ya donc une amertume d'un
côté comme de l'autre cas c'est parler
après et j michel c'était francine qui
le je ne peux pas vous répondre à cette
question parce que je n'ai pas je n'ai
pas si vous voulez de preuves tangibles
d'accord bien en tous les cas votre
livre est évidemment un hommage à votre
père mais sa statue sera un petit peu
ébréché tout ça non quand même non je
pense pas je pense c'est un personnage
absolument extraordinaire qui nous a
appris beaucoup de choses et je lui en
suis très reconnaissant il ya quand même
des seniors comme une scène terrible à
un moment votre frère philippe un
accident d'hydravion son corps tombent
dans le tages ont retrouve son corps et
au moment d'aller reconnaître à la
morgue
votre père n'y va pas et vous envoie
vous rock va nous on attend du
commandant cousteau qu'il ya et qu'il
soit courageux enfin voila c'est captain
planet quoi et
il va pas le captain planet avait une
tendance à déléguer tout ce qui était
désagréable
ouais et en l'occurrence ça a été très
dur pour moi et j'avais fait pour vous
c'est tejedor j'obéis aux commandants et
ensuite c'est quand même beau frère
votre mère parce que le héros principal
du bouquin c'est votre mère enfin cessé
à merci bah oui de me le rappeler bien
sûr un site si j'avais écrit un livre
sur ma mère et il ya d'autres gens qui
ont essayé je ne serais pas là ce soir
or comme j'ai je présente mon père qui
est connu tout le monde ça me permet
d'une façon détournée mais de vraiment
alors voilà excusez moi mais à un moment
votre mère est malade à la fin elle est
victime d'un cancer généralisé l'état
monaco il s'en occupe pas beaucoup il
débarque la veille de sa mort elle a
attendu qu'il fasse surface si j'ose
dire oui pour s'éteindre dans ses bras
[Musique]
alors jean michel cousteau mon père le
commandant s'était dit et à l'archipel
et maintenant on va faire comme votre
père on va s'amuser avec les poissons
on va faire un quiz un quiz fiche
[Musique]
non
vous allez vous reposer tous les deux
alors attention
qu'est ce qu'une astéries étoiles de mer
bon alors attention que se passe-t-il
l'auront concentre toi
concentrez-vous jean-michel que se
passe-t-il quand on casse une branche
des toiles de mer alors tout ce beau
[Applaudissements]
monde est si c'était un piège
je suis méfiant compter des points régis
serge s'il vous plaît pour le moment ça
fait un partout
attention jean michel laurent combien de
coeur à une pieuvre roi bravo quel
animal à près de 9000 dans le requin non
non
la lamproie non quel animal à plus de
9000 dans c'est vrai quoi
je ne sais pas mais pourquoi tu sais pas
ce que j'ai pas encore d' animal qui vit
à la réunion
l'animal marin un animal manger mais là
on est dans le fish crise un coelacanthe
non non
ample et donnez votre langue au chat
parce que c'est le poisson chat
waouh c'est un poisson chat parce qu'il
ya beaucoup d après son achat d'accord
attention quel est l'animal qui a le
plus grand cerveau au monde
c'est un choix qui vaut deux pour un
animal de 15 mètres de long je vous
citer quelques requins vous allez me
dire celui qui n'existe pas à oignies
alors oui ça existe
alors si le requin taupe le requin
taureau le requin zèbre ou le requin
chèvre lequel n'existe pas c'est bon non
chef 2 pour jean-michel allons-y à
combien de temps vit un esturgeon
sentant non 90 ans non 80 60 ans en
disant non à temps sur cinq en or ce
n'était pas aux enchères c'est moi
trente ans personne n'a répondu un
esturgeon jeudi jusqu'à son temps et
d'argent
j'étais quand même c'est vrai oui c'est
vrai vous me donnez donnez un demi point
pour jean michel et moi je persiste à
dire que ça vit plus longtemps que ça
peut vivre jusqu'à 100 ans un esturgeon
avant on est dans la volga tout ça il ya
des spécimens de trois mètres mal et de
ceux qui sont dans les boîtes non match
[Rires]
très intéressant
quelle est la longueur moyenne d'une
bits de baleines en érection de massy
cipriani 2 mètres 40 alors vous dites de
neuf exactement 2 mètres 40
[Applaudissements]
six pieds que je tiens pas non gt gt pas
tout à fait à la langue est un peu court
dans la baie dans la vie mais dans
l'habitacle habite de base
excusez-moi jean-michel oui on parlait
de quelle espèce parce qu'il y en a des
papiers des plus gros en ce domaine
attendant il faut il faut quand même il
faut quand même pas charrier parce que
vous êtes vous avez des petites baleines
les grandes baleines si vous prenez une
baleine bloc est l'animal le plus grand
qui ait jamais existé sur la planète et
elle a rampé de long way
eh bien ça d'être encore plus grand que
ce coup de massue on sait déjà c'est à
dire j'ai vu des deux mètres
j'ai vu plein de l'effet des deux mètres
et où j'ai eu l'idée de mettre parce que
quand malgré les grilles vous avez bien
que quand c'est quand vous avez
un jeune mâle qui est en train
d'apprendre à faire l'amour et que un
vieux mâle est là pour l'assister et une
femelle au milieu de tout ça et bien
vous et cvc verges extraordinaire de
très belles qui se ferme les yeux
absolument remarquable et qui ballot
j'avais un ingénieur du son absolument
extraordinaire effondré qu'ils étaient
fatigués après une journée épuisante on
était tous dans un zodiac en train de se
balancer elle dit dans une petite voix
des verges sur la gauche est elle tout
de suite et caméras en branle
c'est un nouveau nom
quel est le point commun entre un mérou
une dorade grise et un poisson anémone
change de sexe ouais ils sont trop
sexuel avec ces poissons il y en a
beaucoup d'autres espaces il y en a qui
deviennent un mal il ne revient
deviennent femelles et c'est une
histoire de deux qui dominent quoi mais
vous pouvez pas savoir quel est le sexe
d'un d'un de ces poissons hein
et quand vous êtes en présence par
exemple dames et roue et on la filme
mais j'ai des photos qui vous met qu'il
y en a mais o'keefe et 120 kg à peu près
ils vous mettent comme une loche qui
vous mettre leur sexe sur la tête ce qui
m'est arrivé qui vous pousse jusqu'au
fond et qui vous écrasent on se pose des
questions à qu'est ce qu'un pieuvre
argonauts et détonnant pour se
reproduire avec son tentacules elle met
le spermatozoïde son sperme dans la
guilde la famille les tentacules de la
petite pièce voire même aux états
chargés de sperme et part à la recherche
d'une femelle spermatophores
quel est l'autre nom du carassins doré
voilà je suis pas beaucoup quel est
l'autre nom du karaté do ré c'est vrai
parce que c'est qu'un quart à sa d'abord
on est largué nicolas l'autre nom du
queyras under sardines
c'est pas loin c'est un poisson très
simple la rascasse non c'est très très
simple le gobie ne pas le gone
alors c'est le poisson rouge jean-michel
pourquoi jean michel pourquoi la mer est
bleue et bleu à cause de la réfraction
de la lumière bravo laurent pourquoi la
mer rouge et rouge
elle est rouge à cause du du plancton
qui la color ou du sel elle est rouge
oui elle parce qu'elle contient des les
oxydes aider et cher deminor des dés et
les roues sur 7 contient des des non non
non les kroumen des algues
microscopiques
c'est lorsqu'elle est le score si je
suis désolé jean michel vous êtes fait
torcher par le rang de l'achigan matin
[Musique]
michel cousteau mon père le commandant
s'est évité à l'archipel
[Musique]
non je te félicite hu a été exemplaire
vraiment ça m'a fait plaisir
il adore ce salon vous êtes libre non
mais elle cherche un exploit mais il est
bon franchement on est en ce moment en
train de suivre des baleines que nous
avons marqué avec des bouées satellite
et on a besoin d'experts on a besoin de
gens qui savent de quoi il s'agit vous
êtes prêts je suis prêt je pars demain
laurent ça tombe bien je suis libre soit
on cherche pas de nom
j'y vais moi c'est un avion peut
basculer ce soir il n'y a pas que ma vie
était aussi le mal de mer s'est pour sa
part à des pilules honda c'est plus un
problème
c'est extraordinaire bravo et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu